This is 99% indiscible. I'm Roman Mars. On January 3rd, 1979, two officers from the Los Angeles Police Department went to the home of Yule May Love, a 39-year-old African-American mother. The officers were there because of a dispute over an unpaid gas bill. They had been called to her home by the gas company because she had hit the utilities bill collector with a shovel. Mrs. Love was overdue with her $69 payment. The officers approached her and the encounter quickly turned violent. Love allegedly threatened the officers with a knife. They fired 12 times and killed her.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。1979年1月3日，洛杉矶警察局的两名警官来到39岁的非裔美国母亲尤拉·梅·洛夫的家中。警官们到场是因为一笔未付的燃气费纠纷。燃气公司报了警，因为她用铲子打了燃气费催缴员。洛夫夫人的69美元账单已经逾期。警官们接近她时，冲突迅速升级为暴力。据称，洛夫夫人用刀威胁警官。他们开了12枪，将她击毙。
Her neighbors in Watts couldn't believe it. They could have seduced this lady without using the weapons that they used. It could have took her alive, plain and simple, because it was two cops against one lady with the butcher knife. Neither of the two offices involved were prosecuted for the killing. That's George Lavender, a criminal justice reporter at KCRW in Los Angeles. The shooting spout protests and calls for the resignation of the chief of police. In the months since, blacks and liberals have become intensely critical of what they
她在瓦茨的邻居们简直不敢相信。他们本可以在不使用那种武器的情况下制服这位女士。他们本可以活捉她，简单明了，因为是两名警察对付一名拿着菜刀的女士。涉事的两名警官都没有因这起杀戮受到起诉。说话的是洛杉矶KCRW电台的刑事司法记者乔治·拉文德。这次枪击事件引发了抗议，并要求警察局长辞职。在此后的几个月里，黑人和自由派人士对他们所指控的
charge is excessive use of force by the Los Angeles Police Department. The American Civil Liberties Union says that in the last four years, officers here have shot over 300 people, killing nearly half of them. Even though police shootings had been happening for years, and of course still happening today, the killing of Yulaluv received a lot of media attention. That put pressure on the department to respond. The Los Angeles Board of Police Commissioners recommended changes to training
洛杉矶警察局过度使用武力的问题进行了猛烈抨击。美国公民自由联盟表示，在过去四年里，这里的警官射杀了300多人，其中近一半人死亡。尽管警察枪击事件多年来一直发生，当然今天仍在发生，但尤拉·洛夫的死引起了媒体的高度关注。这给警察局带来了回应的压力。洛杉矶警察委员会建议对培训
and the way shootings by officers were investigated. And the killing also led the department to research non-lethal weapons to see if there was some alternative that might reduce the LAPD's reliance on guns. We needed to find a way to control people. Was there something that we could do before we had to shoot them, before they had an opportunity to attack and get shot? That's Greg Meyer. He's a retired captain with the LAPD, and in 1979, he was given the job of researching
以及警官枪击事件的调查方式进行改革。这起杀戮还促使警察局研究非致命性武器，看看是否有某种替代方案可以减少洛杉矶警察局对枪支的依赖。“我们需要找到一种控制人的方法。在我们不得不开枪之前，在他们有机会攻击并被射杀之前，我们能做些什么吗？”说话的是格雷格·迈耶。他是洛杉矶警察局的一名退休警长，1979年，他被指派负责研究
non-lethal weapons for the department. And what we were looking for was something that was effective at subduing a person so that they could be handcuffed expeditiously without a big fight. Maya and the LAPD set out to find a new tool that they hoped would help avoid needless deaths and injuries. The police chief at the time, Darrell Gates, told the Los Angeles Times, quote, what we need is that thing you used to see in Buck Rogers, that thing you used to zap him. Freeze him. Stop him. Ever since the beginning of policing, officers have been looking for tools to subdue people
警察局的非致命性武器。我们寻找的是一种能有效制服嫌疑人的工具，这样他们就能在不发生激烈冲突的情况下迅速被戴上手铐。迈耶和洛杉矶警察局着手寻找一种新工具，希望它能帮助避免不必要的死亡和伤害。当时的警察局长达里尔·盖茨对《洛杉矶时报》说：“我们需要那种你在《巴克·罗杰斯》里看到的东西，那种能电击他的东西。冻结他。阻止他。”自警务工作开始以来，警官们一直在寻找制服
that they consider threatening. When police first started to patrol the streets of America's cities, many carried sticks. In 19th century New York, cops actually had two sticks to choose from, a shorter stick for the day, and a longer one for the night time, because it was thought that more dangerous criminals would come out after dark. That bigger stick became known as the Night Stick. It's called by other names too, the Billy Club, Truncheon, Baton. By the early 1900s, lots of police departments across the country were equipping their officers with guns, but Night Stick remained the alternative weapon of choice.
他们认为具有威胁性的人的工具。当警察最初开始在美国城市的街道上巡逻时，许多人带着棍子。在19世纪的纽约，警察实际上有两种棍子可以选择：白天用短棍，晚上用长棍，因为人们认为更危险的罪犯会在天黑后出现。那根更大的棍子后来被称为“警棍”。它还有其他名字，如比利棒、警棍、短棍。到了20世纪初，全国许多警察局都为警官配备了枪支，但警棍仍然是首选的替代武器。
In the 1960s, that began to change. There was a lot of interest in using new weapons to control alternative weapon of choice. In the 1960s that began to change. There was a lot of interest in using new weapons to control large crowds of people. Many of those weapons, like tear gas, came straight from the military. But some police departments started using a new electrical weapon, the cattle prod. They're designed to move cattle by providing a very focused pain on the body. That's Darius Rijali. He teaches political science at Reed College and has written about the history of electrical weapons
在20世纪60年代，这种情况开始改变。人们对使用新武器来控制大量人群产生了浓厚兴趣。其中许多武器，如催泪瓦斯，直接来自军队。但一些警察局开始使用一种新的电子武器——电牛棒。它们的设计初衷是通过对身体施加高度集中的疼痛来驱赶牛群。说话的是大流士·里贾利。他在里德学院教授政治学，并撰写过关于电子武器历史
and torture. They're usually two electrodes separated by about two inches and they provide a sudden sharp blast of voltage, which moves a person to comply with commands. Police began to use cattle prods against protesters during the Civil Rights Movement in addition to attack dogs and firehoses. Cattle prods emerged in the hands of the Alabama
和酷刑的文章。它们通常有两个相隔约两英寸的电极，能产生突然而尖锐的电压冲击，迫使人服从命令。除了警犬和消防水龙，警察在民权运动期间开始使用电牛棒对付抗议者。电牛棒早在1961年就出现在阿拉巴马州和
Mississippi police as early as 1961. And by 1964, they had become quite common and also quite contentious. Because people objected to being treated like cattle. In 1963, a New York Times article described Alabama highway patrolman using cattle prods on a group of African-American freedom walkers. The Times reported, quote, as one of the Negroes flinched and twisted in the grip of the four troopers, an elderly
密西西比州的警察手中。到1964年，它们已经变得相当普遍，也相当具有争议性。因为人们反对被像牲畜一样对待。1963年，《纽约时报》的一篇文章描述了阿拉巴马州公路巡警对一群非裔美国“自由步行者”使用电牛棒的情景。《纽约时报》报道称：“当其中一名黑人在四名警官的控制下畏缩扭动时，一位年迈的
toothless white man shouted from a roadside pasture, stick him again, stick him again. In quote, people were offended by these stories and images. But there were also proponents of electrical weapons who thought they were better than bludgeoning people with sticks. Better a few joints of electricity than a knockout blow on the head. That's Richard Dordy, a former deputy police commissioner of New York City advocating for electrical prods on ABC in 1968. What is a nightstick after all? It's a club, it's no stick, it makes the cops look like ugly primitives when they use the thing, and it makes the people who
没牙的白人男子在路边的牧场里大喊：‘再电他一下，再电他一下。’”人们对这些故事和画面感到愤怒。但也有电子武器的支持者认为，它们比用棍子殴打人要好。“与其在头上重重一击，不如来点电击。”这是理查德·多迪在1968年的美国广播公司节目中为电击棒辩护时说的话。“警棍到底是什么？它就是根棍子，它不是什么好东西，当警察使用它时，看起来就像丑陋的原始人，而且它会让那些
get hit, as well as the thousands who watch such scenes on television, hate the police more than before. Now, why does this have to be? Why in this age of science and alleged enlightenment do our police have to use a weapon that is right out of the stone age? As it turned out, an inventor named Jack Cover was thinking about these questions, too. Instead of a weapon from the Stone Age, he wanted to create one right out of the space age.
被打的人，以及成千上万在电视上看到这些场景的人，比以前更痛恨警察。现在，为什么非要这样呢？为什么在这个科学和所谓启蒙的时代，我们的警察必须使用一种来自石器时代的武器？”事实证明，一位名叫杰克·科弗的发明家也在思考这些问题。他不想制造一种来自石器时代的武器，他想创造一种来自太空时代的武器。
But whether it would be any more enlightened is debatable. Cover worked as an aerospace scientist and had been involved with NASA's Apollo program. In the late 60s, as images of protests and police violence saturated the nightly news, Kovar came up with an idea, a weapon that would temporarily immobilize a person at a distance using electricity. For several years Kovar worked to develop this device, and finally he created something that worked. He named his new invention after a science fiction novel from his childhood called Tom Swift and his electric rifle.
但它是否会更“开明”还有待商榷。科弗曾是一名航空航天科学家，参与过美国国家航空航天局的阿波罗计划。60年代末，随着抗议和警察暴力的画面充斥着每晚的新闻，科弗产生了一个想法：一种能在远距离暂时使人失去行动能力的电子武器。科弗花了几年时间开发这种装置，最终他创造出了一种有效的产品。他以童年时期的一本科幻小说《汤姆·斯威夫特和他的电步枪》为自己的新发明命名。
In the book, Tom Swift's electric rifle is a lethal device that fires balls of electricity that can pass through walls and penetrate armor. Cova's electric rifle, on the other hand, was intended to be non-lethal, something that could be used to incapacitate a person without injuring them. To name the weapon, Cova took the initials from Tom Swift's electric rifle, T-S-E-R. And then he added an A to make the word easier to say, Taser. You enter a new space age weapon that stands but does not kill the victim. Science-Innerger Jules Bergman has details in this report.
在书中，汤姆·斯威夫特的电步枪是一种致命装置，能发射穿透墙壁和盔甲的电球。而科弗的电步枪旨在成为非致命武器，用于在不伤害人的情况下使人丧失行动能力。为了给武器命名，科弗取了“汤姆·斯威夫特电步枪”的首字母缩写T-S-E-R。然后他加了一个A，使这个词更容易发音，即“Taser”（泰瑟枪）。你进入了一个新的太空时代武器，它能使受害者瘫痪但不会杀死他们。科学记者朱尔斯·伯格曼在报道中提供了细节。
It's called the Taser and they claim it's the first gold tentative of a gun. It looks like a large flashlight. You shine the beam to light up the target, press the switch, and it fires two guards at the intruder. The taser used a small gunpowder charge to fire the two metal darts. The gunpowder meant that some of the early tasers were categorized as firearms. A tiny part of the drive proposed a bomb drive which would have to find wires. The wires carried 50,000 volts in time from a rechargeable battery in short-first. When both the darts hit a target electricity would flow along the metal wires causing the muscles
“它被称为泰瑟枪，他们声称它是枪支的第一个替代品。它看起来像一个大手电筒。你用光束照亮目标，按下开关，它就会向入侵者发射两枚飞镖。”泰瑟枪使用少量火药装药来发射两枚金属飞镖。火药意味着早期的泰瑟枪被归类为枪支。驱动装置的一小部分是一个小型炸弹驱动器，它会连接电线。电线在短时间内从可充电电池中传输5万伏电压。当两枚飞镖击中目标时，电流会沿着金属线流动，导致肌肉
to tense up involuntarily. The high of old-est guards hit, clean the clothing, and send its guards of temporal and parallelized muscles incapacitating the attacker. The guards conduct right through the clothing. They don't have to penetrate flesh. The cattle prods police departments had been using delivered painful assaults of electricity to make someone move.
不自主地收缩。高压电击中目标，穿透衣服，发出电脉冲使肌肉瘫痪，从而使攻击者丧失行动能力。飞镖直接穿透衣服导电。它们不需要刺入皮肤。警察局一直在使用的电牛棒是通过痛苦的电击来迫使人移动。
The taser, on the other hand, used electricity to immobilize them. Cover patented his weapon for immobilization and capture in 1974, instead of approaching police departments across the country to see if they were interested in buying his invention, but he didn't get much traction at first. It's important to recognize it. In its early days, police were absolutely not interested in this weapon. They could imagine what would happen if a, I think I believe the line was a crazy hippie
而泰瑟枪则利用电流使人失去行动能力。科弗在1974年为他的这种用于制服和捕获的武器申请了专利，并开始接触全国各地的警察局，看看他们是否有兴趣购买他的发明，但他起初并没有引起多大反响。必须认识到，在早期，警察对这种武器绝对不感兴趣。他们能想象如果一个——我想那句话是——“疯狂的嬉皮士”
grabbed the end of a taser and wrapped it around the neck of a policeman with all this electrical wire. Nobody wanted to go near it with a 10-foot pole. So, Cove tried to find other buyers like the Army, but that didn't work out. He then tried the airline industry. He wanted to create a light device, one that could be handled by a female stewardess, to incapacitate a would-be terrorist or hijacker, I guess, in those days. But airlines ended up addressing their hijacking problem
抓住了泰瑟枪的末端，并用这些电线缠住警察的脖子会发生什么。没人想用十英尺长的杆子去碰它。所以，科弗试图寻找其他买家，比如军队，但没成功。然后他尝试了航空业。他想制造一种轻便的装置，一种可以由女乘务员操作的装置，用来制服当时的潜在恐怖分子或劫机者。但航空公司最终通过
with the introduction of metal detectors and X-ray machines that screened passengers and their belongings before they got on the plane. Throughout the 70s, Kovac kept tweaking the design of his taser and shopping it around to potential customers, but except for a handful of small police departments, he really didn't have much success. Then finally, in 1979, he found a good match, one of the biggest police departments in the country, the LAPD. As it turned out, the taser seemed to be exactly what the department had been looking for. A device the police could use to, quote, zap him, freeze him, and stop him. So the things would be handcuffed expeditiously without a big fight.
引入金属探测器和X光机来解决劫机问题，在乘客登机前对他们及其行李进行筛查。整个70年代，科弗一直在改进泰瑟枪的设计并向潜在客户推销，但除了少数几个小型警察局外，他并没有取得多大成功。直到1979年，他终于找到了一个合适的买家，即全国最大的警察局之一——洛杉矶警察局。事实证明，泰瑟枪似乎正是该局一直在寻找的东西。一种警察可以用来“电击他、冻结他、阻止他”的装置。这样嫌疑人就能在不发生激烈冲突的情况下迅速被戴上手铐。
Since the killing of Yula Love, Greg Meyer at the LAPD had been searching for an effective non-lethal weapon. The department looked at things like chemical sprays, beanbag rounds, and rubber bullets. We also looked at all kinds of contraptions, including a net and something called the action control chain that was very complicated. Meyer says the LAPD even spent a day at the Los Angeles Zoo
自尤拉·洛夫被杀以来，洛杉矶警察局的格雷格·迈耶一直在寻找一种有效的非致命性武器。警察局研究了化学喷雾、豆袋弹和橡胶子弹等东西。我们还研究了各种各样的装置，包括网和一种非常复杂的所谓“行动控制链”。迈耶说，洛杉矶警察局甚至在洛杉矶动物园花了一天时间
to see if it might be possible to use tranquilizer darts. They're not ready. Then, and they're still not ready now for human use, too dangerous, too many animals die when tranquilizer guns are used. And that's when they already know the animals diet and weight and habits. So when Cobra came along with his taser, the department wasn't intrigued. But first, Meyer needed to see how it might work. My job was to figure out, okay, is it really a good idea?
看看是否可以使用镇静剂飞镖。它们当时还没准备好，现在也不适合人类使用，太危险了，使用镇静枪时会有太多动物死亡。而且那还是在他们已经知道动物的饮食、体重和习性的情况下。所以当科弗带着他的泰瑟枪出现时，警察局很感兴趣。但首先，迈耶需要看看它如何工作。“我的工作是弄清楚，好吧，这真的是个好主意吗？”
Does it really work in real life on the street? Not just in a testing environment, but in real police situations out there. So the LAPD took the taser out onto the streets of South Los Angeles and began to test it, actually using it on people they were trying to subdue and apprehend. At first, the device didn't do what the police wanted, and so they asked Cobra to increase the power, which he did, and then they took it out for more testing. And within just six or ten days, you days, we knew we had a winner. The LAPD put in an order for several hundred tasers,
“它在现实生活中，在街头上真的有效吗？不仅仅是在测试环境中，而是在真实的警察执勤情况下。”于是，洛杉矶警察局将泰瑟枪带到了南洛杉矶的街头，开始进行测试，实际上是在他们试图制服和逮捕的人身上使用它。起初，该装置没有达到警察想要的效果，所以他们要求科弗增加功率，他照做了，然后他们又拿出去进行更多测试。在短短六到十天内，我们就知道我们找到了赢家。洛杉矶警察局订购了几百支泰瑟枪，
and other police departments would soon follow. Today, tasers are a huge business. Almost all tasers used by police in the US are made by one company, Taser International. Founded by two brothers, Rick and Tom Smith in the early 90s, the company worked with Cove to expand on his original invention. Over 80% of all law enforcement departments in the US now use tasers. When Jack Cove died in 2009, his wife told the New York Times that he believed his invention
其他警察局也很快效仿。今天，泰瑟枪是一个巨大的产业。美国警察使用的几乎所有泰瑟枪都由一家公司制造：泰瑟国际公司。该公司由里克·史密斯和汤姆·史密斯两兄弟在90年代初创立，与科弗合作扩展了他的原始发明。美国超过80%的执法部门现在使用泰瑟枪。当杰克·科弗在2009年去世时，他的妻子告诉《纽约时报》，他相信他的发明
had saved 100,000 lives. But of course, the story of tasers is way more complicated than that. For one thing, it's tough to say if tasers have or have not saved lives. Data on both police shootings and taser use are notoriously unreliable here in the US, and even if they're not designed to be lethal, tasers still produce an incredible amount of pain. I know that first hand, because back in the summer of 2015, I volunteered to be tasered. I met up with two taser instructors who worked for the Los Angeles Sheriff's Department, Deputy Chris, Saldana, and Deputy Ed Clark.
已经挽救了10万人的生命。但当然，泰瑟枪的故事远比这复杂得多。首先，很难说泰瑟枪是否真的挽救了生命。在美国，关于警察枪击和泰瑟枪使用的数据非常不可靠，而且即使它们不是为了致命而设计的，泰瑟枪仍然会产生难以置信的痛苦。我对此有第一手的了解，因为在2015年夏天，我自愿尝试了泰瑟枪。我见到了两名在洛杉矶治安官部门工作的泰瑟枪教练，克里斯·萨尔达纳副警长和埃德·克拉克副警长。
Both of them have been tasered before, and they tell me the only thing I have to worry about is ruining my shirt. It's going to be a blend, it's going to be a whole thing. You might do anything, you know? I don't care. OK. The tazers used by the LA Sheriff's Department have changed a lot from the models
他们俩以前都试过泰瑟枪，他们告诉我我唯一需要担心的是弄坏我的衬衫。“它会是混纺的，会是一整套东西。你可能会做任何事，你知道吗？”“我不在乎。”“好的。”洛杉矶治安官部门使用的泰瑟枪与杰克·科弗最初开发的型号相比已经发生了很大变化。
first developed by Jack Cove. For a star, they look much more like guns. The one Clark is holding in his hands looks a bit like a plastic toy gun Black with a yellow stripe on the side Modern tasers also use compressed gas instead of gunpowder to fire which means they're no longer considered firearms But the basic function has remained the same when it's fired both darts have to connect with the target to form a circuit Each taser cycle typically lasts five seconds
首先，它们看起来更像枪。克拉克手里拿的那把看起来有点像塑料玩具枪，黑色，侧面有一条黄色的条纹。现代泰瑟枪也使用压缩气体而不是火药来发射，这意味着它们不再被视为枪支。但基本功能保持不变：发射时，两枚飞镖必须连接到目标上才能形成回路。每个泰瑟枪周期通常持续五秒。
to form a circuit. Each taser cycle typically lasts five seconds. So I don't fall and hurt myself, they ask me to lie down. As I get onto the floor, Clark asks if I want to be able to tap out early, meaning stop the electric shock before the five seconds are up. I think if I tap out then I'm happy to go shorter. Then Clark raises the weapon and points it at my back. OK, I'm ready. Taser, taser, taser. I lasted for about two or three seconds before I had to tap out. More than enough time to know that I wanted to do whatever I could to make it stop.
为了形成回路。每个泰瑟枪周期通常持续五秒。为了不让我摔倒受伤，他们让我躺下。当我躺在地板上时，克拉克问我是否想提前结束，意思是想在五秒钟结束前停止电击。我想如果我能提前结束，我很高兴能缩短时间。然后克拉克举起武器，对准我的背部。“好的，我准备好了。”“泰瑟枪，泰瑟枪，泰瑟枪。”我坚持了大约两三秒，然后不得不要求停止。这足以让我知道，我愿意做任何事来让它停下来。
I think what I remember most was just not being able to focus on anything except the feeling in my back or across my body. For those two seconds, it felt like my entire body was out of my control. It was the most intense pain I've ever experienced. After George had recovered, the instructors had to pull the taser barbs out of his skin. Twist and pull? Really, the only medical care to be rendered is a bandit. So it's not like a big hook that's going to tear a hunk of flesh.
我想我记得最清楚的是，除了背部或全身的感觉外，我无法专注于任何事情。在那两秒钟里，感觉我的整个身体都不受控制。这是我经历过的最强烈的痛苦。乔治恢复后，教练们不得不把泰瑟枪的倒钩从他的皮肤里拔出来。“扭转并拉出？真的，唯一需要的医疗护理就是贴个创可贴。”所以它不像那种会撕下一块肉的大钩子。
My back was sore for a few days, and it took about a week for the puncture weren't to heal, but the memory of the experience stayed with me for longer. I kept replaying it over and over in my head for several weeks afterwards. In the fact is, George had it easy. Most people who get taser don't do so voluntarily. They don't have the option of tapping out when they've had enough. And in the real world, the effects of tasers can be much worse. Tasers are now referred to as less lethal weapons rather than non-lethal. In part, that's an acknowledgement that any weapon can be fatal. Even a blow from a nightstick can kill
我的背部酸痛了几天，穿刺伤口花了一周左右才愈合，但这段经历的记忆却伴随了我更久。在接下来的几周里，我一直在脑海中反复回放。事实上，乔治还算幸运。大多数被泰瑟枪击中的人并非自愿。他们没有在受够了之后选择停止的权利。在现实世界中，泰瑟枪的影响可能会糟糕得多。泰瑟枪现在被称为“低致命性”武器，而不是“非致命性”。在某种程度上，这是承认任何武器都可能是致命的。即使是警棍的一击也可能杀死
someone. There is no use of force that is completely safe. According to a report by Amnesty International, medical examiners have listed tasers as a cause or a contributing factor in more than 60 deaths in the United States between 2001 and 2012. And a 2014 article in the Journal of the American Heart Association concluded that the taser could cause cardiac arrest. Taser International's training materials warn that its weapons can quote, cause death, but the company is really statement stressing that they are quote, generally safe. After Yula loves death in 1979, the LAPD set out to find a new weapon to reduce their alliance
某人。没有任何武力使用是绝对安全的。根据国际特赦组织的一份报告，法医将泰瑟枪列为2001年至2012年间美国60多起死亡事件的原因或促成因素。美国心脏协会杂志2014年的一篇文章得出结论，泰瑟枪可能导致心脏骤停。泰瑟国际公司的培训材料警告说，其武器可以“导致死亡”，但该公司确实发表声明强调它们是“通常安全”的。1979年尤拉·洛夫死后，洛杉矶警察局着手寻找一种新武器来减少对枪支的依赖
on guns and improve their relationship with the community. But it's not clear that tasers are succeeding at this central purpose, even in the majority of cases when they don't contribute to a person's death. The use of these weapons really drives a wedge between the police and the communities that they serve. These weapons and seeing them deployed seems on its face to be somewhat barbaric. That's Tom Nolan. My name is Tom Nolan. I'm an associate professor of criminology at Merrimack College in
并改善他们与社区的关系。但目前尚不清楚泰瑟枪是否达到了这一核心目的，即使在大多数没有导致人员死亡的情况下也是如此。使用这些武器确实在警察和他们服务的社区之间造成了隔阂。这些武器以及看到它们被部署，表面上看起来有些野蛮。说话的是汤姆·诺兰。“我叫汤姆·诺兰。我是马萨诸塞州梅里马克学院的犯罪学副教授。”
Massachusetts. For 27 years I was a city of Boston police officer. The taser didn't solve the problem of excessive use of forests or police shootings. In fact, some researchers have found that cops are reaching for their taser far too quickly and too often in situations that don't justify it. The more weapons we have, of course, the police are going to use them. I mean, it's become the default compliance tool. And while information on taser use across the country is patchy, in several jurisdictions, there's evidence that they're being used disproportionately on people of color, juveniles,
“我曾担任波士顿市警察27年。”泰瑟枪并没有解决过度使用武力或警察枪击的问题。事实上，一些研究人员发现，警察在根本不合理的局势中，伸手去拿泰瑟枪的速度太快、频率太高。“我们拥有的武器越多，警察当然就越会使用它们。我的意思是，它已经成为默认的合规工具。”虽然全国范围内关于泰瑟枪使用的数据并不完整，但在几个司法管辖区，有证据表明它们被不成比例地用于有色人种、青少年
and people with mental health issues. In a 2016 Department of Justice report found that Baltimore, Maryland, police use of tasers was often, quote, unnecessary and unreasonable. Additionally, the Baltimore Sun found that people were sometimes being tasered for longer than the 15-second limit taser international recommends. In one case, a black man named Anthony Howard was tasered nine times for a total of 37 seconds. He stopped breathing and died shortly afterward.
和心理健康问题患者身上。2016年司法部的一份报告发现，马里兰州巴尔的摩市警察使用泰瑟枪的行为往往是“不必要且不合理的”。此外，《巴尔的摩太阳报》发现，人们有时被电击的时间超过了泰瑟国际公司建议的15秒限制。在一个案例中，一名叫安东尼·霍华德的黑人男子被电击了9次，总计37秒。他停止了呼吸，不久后死亡。
Video of the incident shows that when Howard was first tasered, he was standing still, holding a child scooter. After he dropped the scooter and fell, officers continued to shock him. Tazers were originally sold as a way to respond to dangerous situations, like the kind where someone had a knife without having to resort to using a gun. But Nolan says that's not how they're being used. I think the concern that we should all have is that the police are using these weapons unnecessarily in situations where someone has just, as they say in the police world, someone
事件视频显示，霍华德第一次被电击时，他正站着，手里拿着一个儿童滑板车。在他扔掉滑板车倒下后，警官们继续电击他。泰瑟枪最初作为应对危险情况（比如有人拿刀）的手段出售，无需诉诸枪支。但诺兰说，它们的使用方式并非如此。“我认为我们都应该担心的是，警察在一些情况下不必要地使用这些武器，而这些情况仅仅是——正如他们在警察世界中所说的——某人
has flunked the attitude test. The real solution to the issue of police community relations isn't a tool or a technology. The alternative to this is to initiate institutional change and cultural, subcultural change in police agencies. That's something that is extraordinarily difficult to undertake let alone accomplish. It's a change we have to undertake, even if it is extraordinarily difficult, because there is no magic bullet. 99% Invisible was produced this week by George Lavender, Delany Hall, Katie Mingle, and Sharif Usif, with Kurt Coles' stead Avery, Truffleman, Sam Green's fan Emmett Fitzgerald, Terran Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. Part of the story originally aired on KCRW,
‘没通过态度测试’。”解决警民关系问题的真正方案不是某种工具或技术。解决这个问题的替代方案是在警察机构内部发起制度变革和文化、亚文化变革。这是一项极其困难的任务，更不用说完成了。这是一项我们必须承担的变革，即使它极其困难，因为没有灵丹妙药。《99%隐形》本周由乔治·拉文德、德莱尼·霍尔、凯蒂·明格尔和谢里夫·尤西夫制作，库尔特·科尔斯泰德、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、萨姆·格林斯潘、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、泰兰·马扎和我，罗曼·马尔斯共同参与。部分故事最初在KCRW播出，
special thanks to Joe Dominic, Matt Stroud, and Brendan Baker, and special thanks to Melodium and Okia Kumi for their music. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and join discussions about this show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org, run Instagram and Tumblr too. If you want all the stories, the full experience of 99PI, there's only one place to go.
特别感谢乔·多米尼克、马特·斯特劳德和布伦丹·贝克，特别感谢Melodium和Okia Kumi提供的音乐。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW电台的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心“广播街”制作。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg，我们也有Instagram和Tumblr账号。如果你想获得所有故事，获得99PI的完整体验，只有一个地方可以去。
99PI.org Radio Topea From PRX you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
99PI.org Radio Topia 来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。